so former president trump was actually
able to get some lawyers to represent
him
in the upcoming senate impeachment trial
trump's new lawyers david showing and
bruce castor seem to have a reasonable
professional background but as we've
seen time and time again sometimes
having a reasonable background
doesn't mean you're not a mag-a-hat
crazy person and here one of the lawyers
is his solo practitioner who has been
working with roger stone and is an
epstein truther
and the other was a career prosecutor
who was also the former solicitor
general for pennsylvania which is a big
big job
but also apparently was one of the
prosecutors who did not prosecute bill
cosby in the early 2000s of course one
of the lawyers has already gone on tv
and said the riots aren't relevant to
the impeachment trial
this has nothing to do with president
trump and the country doesn't need to
just watch videos
of riots and unrest so it remains to be
seen whether they will go along with
former president trump's crazy strategy
of saying that it was all justified and
that it was all based on election fraud
but subscribe or i will see you
in court